[Music]
whether they're in the deserts of
Albuquerque New Mexico or the suburbs of
Quahog Rhode Island these iconic shows
don't have a single upstanding character
in sight
as one of the earliest examples of
lovably irredeemable characters on
television Seinfeld gave us characters
who were deliberately flawed Vain and
insensitive created by comedians Larry
David and Jerry Seinfeld the show ran
for nine Seasons from 1989 to 1998.
Jerry Seinfeld plays a
semi-fictionalized version of himself as
an up-and-coming stand-up comedian he
acts as the straight man for his
eccentric friends but that doesn't make
him any better than the rest George
Costanza is Jerry's best friend he's
also a lying jealous cowardly loser a
few of his schemes have included lying
about being disabled to get a job
drugging his boss and allowing a serial
killer to escape from police custody his
chronic cheapness even results in the
death of his fiancee which he's not so
secretly pleased about I'm disturbed I'm
depressed I'm inadequate I got it all
Georgia's only saving grace is that he's
not Jerry's neurotic neighbor Kramer
whose impulsive callous nature often
gets him into trouble even Elaine the
only woman in the main cast is
frequently selfish manipulative and
cruel thankfully all these traits make
for absurd situations that are played
for Laughs in fact the cast seemed witty
charming and likable enough that many
viewers took umbrage with the show's
finale which finally showed them
receiving consequences for their actions
but whether in jail or on the streets of
New York these are some crazy characters
you probably wouldn't want to come
across
one of TV's most controversial programs
South Park is teaming with irredeemable
characters just like the show itself the
citizens of this small Colorado Town
push boundaries and challenge political
correctness every chance they get Stan
Marsh Kyle broflovsky Eric Cartman and
Kenny McCormick may be eternally stuck
in fourth grade but there's nothing
innocent about these boys some low
lights include Cartman cooking his
Bully's parents into Chile and force
feeding it to him Kyle repeatedly
abusing his brother Stan ending a
short-lived piece in the Middle East and
Kinney abetting in the murder of Sarah
Jessica Parker it's not just the boys
that have issues either other recurring
characters are just as bad if not worse
Stan's girlfriend Wendy pays terrorists
to have the class's new substitute
teacher shot into the Sun towally the
living towel repeatedly offers drugs to
children but Stan's dad Randy may be the
worst of all he's gotten into fist
fights at Little League games persuaded
world leaders into nuking Finland and in
more recent years he started the
covid-19 pandemic the Unapologetic
absurdity of South Park was unlike
anything that came before it was the
first animated series to receive a tvma
rating and remains one of the highest
rated shows on Comedy Central
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
premiered on August 4th 2005 and has
been renewed up to its 18th season
making it the longest running
live-action sitcom of all time it made
waves when it first debuted for its
controversial comedic style and its
sociopathic gang of main characters
Charlie Dennis Mack and Dee were
responsible for plenty of excellent gags
by themselves but the show truly came
into its own when it introduced Danny
DeVito as Frank it's my character I'm
the trash man I come out I throw trash
all over all over the ring
there is not an ounce of shame or
remorse following any of the gang's
criminal immoral Antics they've
kidnapped a bar critic after a bad
review burned down an immigrant family's
home and faked a funeral for a
non-existent baby to fool the IRS Dennis
is particularly malevolent he's stolen a
man's identity stalked a manipulated
countless women and he may or may not be
a serial killer of course one of the
gang's overall greatest sins has been
their treatment of Rickety Cricket a
former priest that they physically and
mentally tortured over the show's many
seasons maybe it's the dark comedy or
morbid curiosity that keeps viewers
coming back for more but if there's one
lesson we can learn from always sunny
it's to stay as far away from people
like this as possible
the Gallaghers are probably TV's most
dysfunctional family led by Frank the
neglectful alcoholic father of six the
oldest child Fiona is left to raise the
rest of the kids on her own but not even
she can save them from their
self-destructive Destinies Fiona may
have stepped up when Frank wouldn't but
she's no saint either on top of being a
liar manipulator serial cheater and
homewrecker Fiona caused the youngest
Gallagher Liam to suffer a near fatal
drug overdose the rest of the kids have
their own problems in addition to their
Petty criminality the intellectual
Prodigy lip uses his gifts in all the
wrong ways from taking the SATs for
other students to organizing wire fraud
Ian kidnapped a baby and has sent
at-risk youth to jail for his own
benefit Debbie lied about being on the
pill and trapped her boyfriend with a
pregnancy Carl is an outright criminal
selling guns at school and dealing drugs
there was also the time when all the
kids attempted to murder their father by
throwing him off a bridge although some
could argue that he may have had it
coming
what's worse than a dysfunctional family
a dysfunctional family with power in
succession the Roy's are the owners of
the global media and entertainment
conglomerate waystar royco and they'll
do anything to control public perception
and make lots of money doing so led by
their vulgar patriarch Logan they freely
and unapologetically lie to and
manipulate others they cover up scandals
like it's a hobby and break the law like
it's going out of style when they're not
destroying the world they're destroying
each other needless to say they're not
exactly the most ethical Bunch Logan Roy
School of Journalism
what's next the Jack the Ripper Women's
Health Clinic
horrible highlights from this family
include shiv manipulating her husband
into an open relationship on their
wedding day and cousin Greg covering up
a massive abuse Scandal by shredding
important documents Roman sexually
harasses women Logan verbally and
emotionally abuses his children and most
shocking of all Kindle's recklessness
and irresponsibility leads to the death
of a young man it seems that once you
get a taste of power There's No Going
Back
created by and starring Bill Hader Barry
is a black comedy drama about a Hitman
from the Midwest Who falls in love with
acting while on a job in Los Angeles
Barry may be a cold-blooded killer but
he's ready to leave that life behind and
turn a new Leaf as an actor even if he's
not very good at it at all this proves
to be more difficult than he originally
thought no matter how hard he tries he
can't escape his dark past throughout
the series it becomes impossible for him
to juggle his conflicting lives as he
becomes more and more unhinged Barry's
victim count is higher than 15 in season
one alone several of whom trusted him
until the very end his escapades grow
Wilder in season two in which he fights
a pre-teen martial arts master and mows
down an entire Monastery full of
criminals the people around Barry aren't
exactly Saints either his Handler Fuchs
is willing to throw anyone and everyone
under the bus to save himself his
girlfriend Sally is narcissistic and
often crew rule to others his acting
teacher Jean cousinao is a greedy absent
father even NoHo Hank the affable
Chechen mobster who can't stand violence
isn't exactly a paragon of morality
don't [ __ ] with me buddy
it's not polite
in Hollywood it's kill or be killed and
that's doubly so in the world of Barry
Walter White is another man trying to
balance a double life in the iconic
crime drama Breaking Bad his Dark
Descent from Modest high school
chemistry teacher to ruthless drug
kingpin makes for one of the best
anti-hero story arcs in TV history
Creator Vince Gilligan has suggested
that it takes fresh eyes years later to
really understand how irredeemable
Walter truly is telling variety he was
really sanctimonious and he was really
full of himself he had an ego the size
of California and he always saw himself
as a victim he was constantly griping
about how the world shortchanged him how
his Brilliance was never given its due
when you take all of that into
consideration you wind up saying why was
I rooting for this guy
you believe that there's a hell I don't
know if you're into that but we're
we're already pretty much going there
right while it's hard to compare to the
villainous nature of Heisenberg himself
his family and colleagues have often
found themselves morally challenged
Walter's partner and former student
Jesse Pinkman helps him cook and sell
meth which means getting caught up in
the deaths of multiple characters Walter
is also to blame for Skylar turning into
a white-collar criminal as she feels
that she has to launder his drug money
to keep her family safe Skyler's sister
Marie is a shoplifter and while Marie's
DEA agent husband Hank tries to be the
hero his short temper leads him to
commit some questionable Deeds like
beating Jesse within an inch of his life
and the criminal lawyer Saul Goodman boy
does he have a story
before he became Walter White's lawyer
in Breaking Bad Saul Goodman was known
as Jimmy McGill a struggling public
defense lawyer living in the shadow of
his brother Chuck in Better Call Saul
the spin-off to Breaking Bad we learn
about Saul's past and how he became the
sleazy lawyer that Albuquerque would
come to know Jimmy spent his youth
ripping people off as a con artist and
after some trouble with the law he
decided to follow the path of his
brother and become a lawyer when that
doesn't really work out for him he leans
back into his scamming Tendencies he
falsifies legal documents demolishes his
brother's reputation and corrupts Kim
with his unethical schemes don't feel
too bad for these other characters
though because they're not exactly
Heroes either Chuck constantly tries to
sabotage Jimmy's career Kim lies about
her identity and causes a man's death
and Mike is simply a cold-blooded killer
there's no real redemption in sight for
these characters and no Happy Endings
either
before Breaking Bad there was The
Sopranos a popular and critically
revered crime drama series following the
Italian mob in New Jersey this HBO show
changed the way we think of heroes and
villains on television Paving the way
for a new generation of prestige TV The
Sopranos centers around James
gandolfini's Tony Soprano a mobster
trying to balance his work family with
his blood family when you're dealing
with violent gangsters it's only natural
to run into some criminal activity and
it doesn't get much worse than the
cold-blooded killings carried out by
multiple characters the dark burden of
this kind of Lifestyle carried into the
real world with one former HBO executive
telling Insider Tony's struggles not
only mirrored James gandolfini's
struggles they Amplified Jimmy struggles
and what Jimmy felt it takes a real toll
on a person to embody someone as
irredeemable yet complex as Tony Soprano
it seems today that all you see is
violence in movies and sex on TV and
there's plenty of crazier things than
that in Family Guy The Animated sitcom
created by Seth MacFarlane revolves
around the Misadventures of Peter
Griffin his wife Lois their kids Chris
Meg and Stewie and their sentient dog
Brian The off-color Comedy of Family Guy
takes the Griffin family down some dark
paths Lois isn't afraid to cheat and
steal to get what she wants the kids
aren't all right as Chris and Meg are
constantly getting into trouble even
little baby Stewie who should be the
most innocent of them all is actually an
evil genius bent on world domination at
least the dog has to be harmless right
far from it Brian has taken advantage of
his girlfriends planted drugs on a
co-worker to have her arrested and has
killed an innocent man for fun but the
biggest offender of them all is
undoubtedly Peter who should probably be
in prison for life he robs banks at
gunpoint commits treason and abuses his
entire family at the drop of a hat dad
can you crack your window a little bit I
hate you all so much
some role model he is
living in a world that has superheroes
might seem cool until your girlfriend is
vaporized by a careless Speedster that's
what happens to Huey Campbell and the
boys sending him down a dangerous path
of murder and Mayhem in this universe
the mega Corporation Vaught has a
monopoly on soups thanks to Decades of
lies and Corruption led by the ruthless
CEO Stan Edgar they're responsible for
America's greatest so-called Heroes
particularly the elite team known simply
as the seven the sevens members like the
recklessly homicidal a train and the
sexual predator the deep are far from
Role Models but none are as monstrous as
their leader homelander with the powers
of Superman and none of his morals this
lab-grown mama's boy is as terrifying as
he is pathetic he prefers to be loved
but if he needs to be feared to get what
he wants that works just fine too that's
why it's up to Huey and the boys to do
whatever they can to take vote down down
even if their methods aren't much more
morally sound led by Billy butcher the
biggest soup hater of them all the boys
aren't afraid to get down and dirty with
blackmail torture and full-blown murder
Huey Frenchy kamiko and mm aren't quite
as diabolical as butcher is but they
always seem to end up going along with
his plans in the world of the boys there
are no real heroes only villains playing
dress-up
[Music]